how does it feel you know to be
nominated now at this point versus you
know thinking about being nominated 13
years ago or even 10 years ago well like
I said we didn't think about it you know
I didn't even realize it there's a 25
year thing you know you're eligible yeah
and then if it happens it happens and if
it doesn't it doesn't
some people get in first nomination
their first and and we didn't ever get
nominated for 13 years and I you know
that people will say to what the people
are on our side say all you should have
happen first time around and then
there's other people that don't care but
when it happened it happened at the same
time as he did for Roxy Music whoo men
eligible for 21 years
yeah and they only just got it yeah so
if you look at it from that point of
view we kind of made it in pretty early
yeah well you're in good company I think
Janet Jackson also Radiohead he said
Roxy Music right yeah and Stevie Nicks
yeah how's that good
all the bands of British which is
astonishing really yeah you know and two
ladies American ladies so yeah it's it's
very eclectic mix I mean Def Leppard in
the Cure can of oil and water musically
if you like yeah same thing with radio I
don't suppose as well but I grew up I
grew up with Roxy Music I grew up with
the zombies go with Stevie Nicks yeah so
you know it is it's kind of it's a nice
thing to being there in the same year as
those guys but there's one of the
beautiful things about rock and roll
music right you've got those different
sounds for you know like you said oil
and water musically right kind of
different this end of the spectrum and
that end is absolutely get to celebrate
together I think it's great you know I
mean they rock and roll in its embryonic
form or its classic old terminology
would be Jerry Lee Lewis mmm Little
Richard Chuck Berry you know and then
new band started using the term rock and
roll to describe themselves when they
weren't really rockin no bones and just
getting a bit more credibility yeah I
was included yes we never had we hated
being called heavy metal so we said
little rock band we're rocking on
you know but you know those all those
guys are there already in the people
that started this mad music off yeah
turning jugs into this thing that is
rock and roll they're already inducted
years ago yeah so let's get to the stage
now where he has to get more eclectic
because the music did over the 60s 70s
80s and 90s it started to change you
know you listen to a lot this 50 stuff
yeah it is very similar yeah and then
you know you can't really say that
Radiohead sound anything like Bon Jovi
you don't sound anything like Depeche
Mode do not sound anything like us sure
yeah and that we covered on their songs
pretty well was yeah you know it's it's
it is good eclectic mix what do you
think about say rock and roll these days
well you know are you hearing anything
that you're thinking yourself you have
this is rock and roll music not much
I'll be honest but the two obvious ones
there's great van fleet which is the big
thing at the moment you know or greater
vans absolutely but I mean yeah they
sound like Led Zeppelin so what you know
yeah when we started out we sounded like
Queen and ac/dc so everybody's got to
start somewhere
yeah it's okay to where you your
influences on your sleeves these days I
believe you know my favorite new band
though are the struts yeah I say new
they've been around for five years five
years in the Beatles career is more than
half their career let's just uh but
things have changed a lot yeah I'm a big
fan of I think Luke this singer is an
absolute star and deserves to be on
Stadium stages yeah hopefully one day he
will be but that's pretty much it yeah I
don't really I don't go searching for it
anymore like when I was 16 I every band
was my band yeah and now it's like let's
sort of just plunk sit in front of
English you've got to listen to this
yeah then I will but I haven't got the
time when you start making your own
music you start to like drop that fanboy
thing you're always a fan I mean I'm
always a fan but seriously my record
collection if I never heard anything
from 1979 onwards for the rest of my
life I'd be a happy boy and that's
coincident we'll only started out yeah
that's when I started concentrating more
than what I do rather than what I listen
to
mm-hmm but you guys are non-stop I mean
you you're working harder now then a lot
of your bands ever you know will ever be
able to work well you can call it yeah I
mean we work in hard it is hard work
yeah but it's when it's your vocation
when it's your hobby and it's your
calling or whatever you want to call it
it doesn't quite seem as hard yeah if if
somebody said to me you've got to go and
climb up everything like really you know
somebody that wants to climb Mount
Everest they were great yeah so they got
there a lot easier than I would this for
me is not that much of a stretch and of
course of work because it's like it's
all I've ever wanted to do so I'm
totally told up for doing it yeah
but you love touring like being on stage
for you like that's the essence of what
you do that's the best part
yeah you know making records is like
shaving man you got to do it unless you
want a beard you know you got to make a
record to be able to go out on the road
well that's how it was he's not even
that way anymore
yeah you can you could we could
seriously make a living for the rest of
our lives without making any new music
whatsoever but it would kill our soul
yeah - never make new music but yeah
playing live when you start out you
normally start out you're a kid 2 3 4
years old and you hear music and then if
you're lucky our generation then you
start to see the bands are performing
because granny's got an old
black-and-white TV or something yeah and
you start seeing top of the pops and all
these Ready Steady goes shindig all
these shows that and show the people
actually playing these music that's what
attracts you in is that visual audio
thing of like you're listening you like
the songs and when you see them and
there's all these people dancing around
you're thinking yeah I'll take some ones
yeah so that's what pulls you in you
never I don't think anybody ever joined
a band think you know I can't wait to
spend three years on this - yeah nobody
said no one ever
so are you guys doing any shaving now so
to speak are you working on anything
right here maybe on Friday afternoon
yeah but anything you know anything new
with this band with Def Leppard well we
all we're constantly doing things you
know I mean we change your focus when
the business changes they say that the
most important thing right now is
promote self promotion yes it's talking
about what you do and then going out and
doing it yeah plain Live has become the
important thing people now maybe put an
album out to promote a tour whereas we
you know traditionally is always being
you've went on tour to promote the
record yeah its flipped so you know we
we have a legacy we have a fantastic
back catalogue to pick from where we
could tour yeah you know forever just
playing what everybody knows and when
people come to live environments they're
not really coming to be educated they're
coming to be entertained so when you go
and see Paul McCartney yes we will
indulge him three new songs in a two
hours for Rolling Stones the same thing
but we're actually there to hear brown
sugar and jumping jack flash or you know
the long and winding road or let it be
McCartney you know we're not there to
hear the new songs really let's be
honest mm-hmm I'll buy the album Elissa
to a tall man if some of them becoming
hit yeah yeah I want to hear them live
yeah don't party me with 12 new songs
yeah because the industry has changed
you can do that I believe in what we
used to like to call open mic nights hmm
go down in a basement in front of 15
people and play in hours of the song
I've never heard and that's exactly what
they expect but if you're McCartney and
you're on stage it you know Madison
Square Gardens it's live or live and let
die and love me do and stuff like that
you